a warning that my report from butcher
includes images of dead bodies being
exhumed
the full cost of occupation takes time
to emerge police searching this Woodland
for mines outside Kiev finding people in
Shallow Graves five months after Russian
troops left the area it's too upsetting
to show you these images too closely but
we can see tape around the body that's
just been found here and the head
appears to have been covered as well and
the police tell me that they found this
person with their hands tied
the mayor of butcher told us 93 of those
killed in his town had bullet wounds
and police say some of the bodies
they're finding here show signs of
torture foreign
after he lost contact with his father in
March months later he learned he was
killed in this garage along with four
others after a photo of his father's
body part and ID was sent to him by a
prosecutor
um
[Music]
feared even worse may be found in the
recently liberated Northeast
a mass burial site is still being
exhumed in isium after nearly half a
year under Russian control
it echoes the Grim discovery of a mass
grave found in butcher after just 33
days occupation in that time more than
350 people were killed here out of the
three and a half thousand who remained
the leafy suburb has now returned to
life but the community carries the
trauma of what happened here
around a fifth of the country remains
under Russian control and there's a
concern many more towns could be going
through similar Horrors to butcher isium
we just don't know about it yet
people killed in ISM in March are only
being recovered now 36 year old Soldier
Raymond costenko returned to his family
in Kiev by his unit six months after his
death
uh
these soldiers are already back on the
front line but the fight for justice is
another Ukraine needs to win they say if
Russian war crimes aren't prosecuted
here they could happen anywhere
[Music]